le deème chapitre porte sur les défis
institutionnels et on a identifié CIN
domaines clés à
réformer on on a parlé du Parlement
européen et notamment on suggère de ne
pas élargir le nombre maximal des
députés qui sont actuellement
et donc on propose d'adopter un nouveau
système de répartition des sièges fondés
sur la formule de Cambridge ensuite pour
le Conseil EUR euréen euh pour le
Conseil de l'Union européenne on a on a
regardé la le fonctionnement notamment
de la présidence de l'Union européenne
euh la présidence qui se fait sur une
période de de 6 mois euh on on trouve
que c'est un élément très important à la
fois pour la gestion du Conseil des
ministres mais aussi pour euh chaque
État membre d'avoir un ownership des
affaires européennes et de pouvoir
communiquer de son propre rôle au sein
sein de l'UE vis-à-vis ses propres
citoyens mais on pense que la
coordination des présidences du Conseil
européen peut être renforcée et on
propose notamment d'avancer du format de
trio c'est-à-dire trois pays membres qui
se coordonnent sur une période de 18
mois d'avancer sur cinq présidences donc
2 ans et demi ce qui veut dire la moitié
du mandat de la Commission européenne et
et du Parlement européen donc comme ça
on pense qu'on pourra mieux coordonner
les initiatives politiques
les coordon mieux avec le programme de
travail avec la Commission européenne et
d'avoir plus de cohérence sur les 5 ans
entre deux élections
européennes pour la Commission
européenne on on a on a choisi de de
parler notamment de la taille et de
l'organisation du collège déjà
aujourd'hui avec 27 commissaires c'est
c'est c'est un c'est une organisation
très complexe et grande et le collège
euh si on l'imagine à à à 35
commissaires commence à devenir trop
lourd il faudra inventer des dossiers
supplémentair pour chaque pays qui
arrive et chaque commissaire qui serait
là euh le traité de Lisbonne offre la
possibilité de réduire la taille du
collège donc sans réforme du traité on
pourrait réduire le nombre de des
commissaires on a présenté ça comme
première option mais on est très
consciente du prix politique que ça peut
avoir si un pays membre n'a pas de de
commissaire pendant une période de de 5
ans donc notre deuxème option qui à
notre avis est
politiquement plus facilement euh
négociable c'est différencier les
commissaires en fait différencier entre
commissaires principaux et commissairire
si vous voulez normaux et donc une une
certaine
hiérarchisation sans nécessairement
réduire le droit de vote si on
choisirait de de réduire le le droit de
vote c'est-à-dire
identif
un groupe qui a les droits de vote au
sein de la Commission et les autres qui
ne l'ont pas il faudra reformer le droit
primaire et donc on ne propose pas ça
parce qu'on pense que c'est trop
difficile